a stroller Tsar looking to try force
this into extra rounds extra innings and
ERV takes out bolts
fallen still loss to the small denying
the wind that donut bullet donut there's
no time to plant shut up a clone no he
hasn't
coal has gone down they just barely get
the kill with one second left up top mid
end all the way over toward a tree and
taps and goes quite cold zeros quicker
gets a second as well as the bomb will
go down and follows it up they're all
lining up cool there are with the NACE a
beautiful one as well and he's elated
for good reason it seemed to kill puff
up in the feet but he will have another
crack not a shot and this time he does
to live Oh
nifty unreal plays purely off sound
instincts if you can scamper past and
the a sight Avery will be right for the
taking a small craft that he can see in
somebody's land it's a scout shot now
this round is back he'll stick fast
since the first man in its gonna take
that way land oh there's console as well
this war brain is a brick so finds
another one just then a 20 left in its
weight same three electronic what are
you doing there's a quad cure for
electronic who even finishes up the job
what are nuts play from electronic
nothing in full duration or get hit by
it a little bit but still have enough
vision to win the exchange and the round
I would say is going to following my
fashion as SK have full control or today
or do they all my goodness automatic for
HP points to kills it's all for naught
perhaps or is it because skadoodle is
actually going on undetected they went
so much automatic another that you have
to be kidding me that is the most insane
round add eagle has had yet in this
tournament I think right now could still
cost him the round he's almost doing it
mo tooling around he gets the kill on
get right and now Dre can have to do it
again in a one on two and he's got no
grenades yeah this is just about all
over isn't it no kit either and now
blows back with the ankle there this
should be impossible from the way that's
a nice flick though but still with the
tenth second he's gotta fight Hobbit off
to the left Oh what is that flick for
Dragon then a four-on-four now grenades
in the corner clearing that up
taco jumping and not seeing anyone
another retake just once on the menu
here the Brazilian boys and he's
actually holding the middle very
aggressive coming up here another trade
in sip and bolts both out the three on
three in that mid player and Dupree is
gonna be a big problem for SK gaming
they need something and there's fallen
picking off one going for the scope
again second kill coming in and he takes
down Tennyson Dupree he can't see a
thing there right in front defusing the
bomb the struggle
if you're holding back go for the show
at the same time the doc that doesn't
walk down a JD f5 without bragging care
indeed dies in the last rows so to see
in this well the auto sniper the gifts
the flick with her best chance except in
the back of the site and he's got
accuracy
get up to the server oh my god that much
by actually flashed the flanker have no
idea how see still gets the kill almost
look like they're coming away only once
a fashion to JW as well the opens of the
chance now very passive waiting gambling
that both players come from the same
side and he is correct in that
assumption nothing he picks up III bring
hurry to be bomb site I'll already
thinking up that first kill he's gonna
have to do a little bit more than that
one though he's fighting in a cage
himself but he's already got three now
four kills trying to go for the full ace
and he might just as well pull it off I
think it's team is hurting him a little
bit of room to work with exists the last
man steady but all what did the map
reload what the heck so more than
anything don't want to make this work
with Steel's cooking it over from homes
of Steel of afraid he's essentially just
running away with this game looking very
good indeed
pastor though all of us is one will see
we can do anything with this bums down a
connector there's the first kill
something to build apart but I'm not
believing just yet up against the double
offset all right now we've got a chance
fifty seconds he's got time to work with
with palm as well they're divided
Neuros biceps big enough to push the
ball because it's stalled and they need
to get to a gas station they desperately
need around back through vent
potentially doesn't want to chance it
movement gets slowed as the site to work
with Lucas who just barely goes under
the crosshair shot from - to 6 HP plants
as open as he possibly they're in the
sights and how does he choose to
approach it stay on the a cake because
neither he was dead
studio one-shot wonder he's gone to work
see team
sans will urge him over and he's gonna
be up daisies he's gonna mold my doctor
events and he just came from there this
was a one versus for the play of Pasha's
life its planet so open and he's gonna
have no idea spoke goes on to it he's
not picking it yet fashion these
patients and he spotted he knows
push it up the clock got wheels on it
still no gasps but
[Applause]
I've ever seen from you this entire
career that is brilliant
he's one of those players that
absolutely can has taken a bit of damage
early on but this should be no chance
just equalize the score always getting
greater the edge of the smoke conf it
doesn't know it's nax trying to sneak up
behind him convict not really aware
what's going on yet this could be a loss
take a very quick and the timing here
this favoring snaps and is he really
going to go for the knife
three down blue dismal walking it's all
up to him and they're ready for it the
spot Emeritus he goes around a corner
everyone faces or a shot fight absent as
he repeats back le WPS to back off
repeat he fights a shot at golf
we got off track murky business shot pin
shot of his yes it does open up the site
Snyder's gonna do instead by wrapping
around the goal for the default plan
just in time five seconds when he gets
it on to the plant and on to the logging
one HP versus two there's 3 HP between
two players left in a 1vs1 post plant
overtime of an elimination match at
config might get the upper hand
take your time take your time injury and
overtime that is bull water by now Nico
that brings it level but watch to his
left side because I don't think he's
aware that Guardians snuck up in this
pistol at this range with no attention
from fer his lethal ease looked a main
but he's not looked real giant Guardians
wifted that could be enough to turn it
because now fer has the information
they're able to work this together and
just the pistols to play what they
needed the kill guardians gotta make up
for it he's tapping him but he can't
find it fallens on the defuse falling
his on the defuse does he deny that in
that situation that should have been
done they then burned down the clock
drove up to 40 second part and tried to
wrap around nice little play and it
works for a frag
unbelievable hits the head shot
regardless and now incident to the 1v1
ceases holding close to the connector
will flush to be able to figure this out
seems to have an idea of it that's could
be lift it let's go think Ali may just
go for the stick on this ball it's gonna
try walk back in as they both get close
enough rain considering up or has a loo
go look brilliant falling into the wall
he won't be spotted it gets one against
flush show-off is still close enough
you'll rotate back oh this is quite
nifty actually I'm not sure he's got a
better chance this is really good from
Glyph he's got a better chance of
finding Olof now for free because he
thinks that outside scum there it is
perfect headshot who will clean it up
that's automatic down as head he finds
the rotations this Russian Tarek but
look at this
there we go get the third one now as
well as he takes down kenji handy now
all of a sudden is the last man standing
tarik makes an amazing player so maybe a
couple of just negates with three
beautiful what times make it a fourth
unreal plays play next up is he gonna
get the ACE gasps he is already pushing
forward to try and find them get the
both in his sights minish is only one JD
I'm within that correct direction but
it's a one versus four AWP push out good
shot JD apples for another he's got this
down to one versus two mover commitment
and perhaps a little bit zealous to try
it early end this another and gets taken
down to the box what is that from JDM
Kenny which is one pretty quickly that's
important yeah not much of a flight
they're not have because got a big job
to do good peek out but he's waiting for
the response there's shocks with a kill
and BK going for more but it's all sweet
in the favor of g2 spreading close he's
gonna get completely drunk by shop
setting face gets a head shot hit sold
on set he's alone he gets one the wall
is right in front of him he's clicking
through the smoke and missing the last
couple of chunks body is solid with the
diffused kid he's gonna get one kill sip
for this bro oh my god he picks it up a
now running back he's kidding me they
they had strong side hole they had they
had automatic as the float they had two
people in that a bomb side I had two
people in the be-bop side you would have
had three at any site once the attacker
couple I think it's just the underlying
issue of fun I'm seeming very or come
for the CT side yeah and they have to go
for a place somewhere right oh look at
this skadoodle doing his best simple
impression with the dropping kill and
actually
cops to smoke doors what alley it's
another that's for kills first skadoodle
he's tapped the bomb his head he gonna
push forward he has plenty of time for
this skadoodle Italy this is the shot
now he's gonna get on the bomb I think
he's just gonna stick a penny he's got a
Glock he's got it he can't find it again
he's got it
skittle is a hero what are you doing
this is Reuben on erupts is able to find
the first shot gonna come in with the
equalizer Batangas jr. now it's kinda
wants as much control as possible at the
bomb site to prevent the enemies players
from rotating it from Z and immediately
take in an apex gonna move forward but
he could get bucked up on a guy in Z if
that custom s was ready for that what he
was expecting it so he takes it down to
now they've lost an end avenge all of a
sudden Kenny and Chuck's versus the
world here in shots
action Kenny first up the back he finds
a shelf at he's being pressured up close
he need shocks his boredom he's wanting
for a playful one squawk oh my god Kenny
it's an incredible kill against sixer I
don't even see the flicky hit that shot
somehow Halloween nico could go straight
in with glaive to watch them off to free
to play a bags could swing back in that
direction because the air is going to be
fresher be nice to know that so
works though I'm an efficient eliminated
weapons Johnson finally do something in
the second offices with a kill as well
on forest with a headshot
crowd in a one on three oh how did that
get so sloppy managed to actually do a
little bit of damage to track it so he
has the info here waiting to see if the
peak is gonna come through but there is
absolutely no reason especially the
track and it's not that angle he's
looking towards a main he's not holding
the e box line and that could cost him
shroud nearly finds the kill on forest
as well trying to pay the response but
he's running so low on time there's the
first shot as the second does he have
time to bacon who does more than enough
get riding just all died off once again
they have two falls by Ravis service
it's cooking breeding so for them right
now my sister's pushing it he's gonna be
taken out by hand pistol trach him take
the second fight
[Music]
no cestus ET au gets him through the
wall drake an absolutely perfect that
could be the difference maker here in
this round
dennis is spamming it through the bench
leaving cold sarah and a wall on for
there's the first looking for what a
play sit but he's got the palm in forty
seconds here the alleys already tacked
up sit there and ready ready waiting for
him right in front can they get the
timing down fascist moving up on the
other side of him and see if he's gotta
be turning his back at the hell - what
health the alley with the patient's play
coming out flashbang is in there now
25 seconds head shot coming in from
septics what compiled he do he has to
find the bomb and make his way onto a
site and look at the angle here this is
not easy the alleyway out in the open he
gets shut down
settings whether water three o'clock oh
my god one health left
there's to start four more kills and
they will have made it at the full
distance snacks and i've got a cop the
opposition he goes down with the max 70
car make it happen finally pasha coming
in with a refract but he's down the bomb
has been picked up by Dupree they get
the spray Neal takes one it out of there
major championship in 1614 against
mother pearl unbelievable
here they are ladies and gentlemen your
major champions astrology
[Applause]
[Music]
our mortal is now feeling like they know
what to do two challenges put on a
position the gambit is send even more
firepower that's bring more balls it's
huge
you're just automating to the corner
just as the
get rained on and gets his vision back
just in time as well as they start to go
to war Rudy was found in this position
last time another good fly okay it's in
the open he's gonna have to rethink that
pose plan that this setup is getting
torn apart okay back in again the third
kill all the way through
[Applause]
the pistol when they go up to take him
down and a ball play than the two versus
two camping just have to hold off they
won't waste much time grouping as still
as the kid kmg is there they picked up a
Khalil to work with five seven to lead
the charge too far away for the shotgun
to be helpful take your pack because he
thinks otherwise they'll go aggressive
no one peeking so he'll take every in
she can get to make this an instant kill
off the shotgun cross fighters and he's
bad still drinking it was real Oregon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]